الهدوء الحظر عادا لارجاء العاصمه
البرازيليه والامن بسطه سيطرته على قصر
الرئاسه ومنشات حيويه اخرى غير ان وضع
احداث الشغب والاحتجاجات بخانه الارهاب
جعلت الاف المعتقلين يواجهون تهاما
عقوبتها وخيمه الشرطه البرازيليه اعتقلت
الفن و500 شخص من انصار الرئيس السابق جير
بورسنارو وهؤلاء اقطعهم مباني الحكوميه في
العاصمه والتخم بالحاق اضرار كبيره
بالمقائد الثلاثه الكونجرس ومكتب الرئيس
والمحكمه العليا في وقت اذان الرئيس من
وصفهم بمسيريب بسبب اعمال الارهابيه
وفارسيه
مئات الجنود ايضا والشرطه خارج مقر الجيش
الرئيسي في البرازيليا وهناك كان انصار
سونارو ينظمون احتجاجا منذ اسابيع وهناك
ايضا جرت معظم الاعتقالات الرئيس
البرازيلي الذي ربح الانتخابات بفارق بسيط
في اكتوبر اجتمع بقاده مجلسي الكونجرس
ورئيس المحكمه العليا بيان المنبثق عن
الاجتماع الثلاثي رفض احداث برازيليه التي
تدخل في اطار التخريب الاجرامي والترويج
للانقلاب اما في العاصمه فاكد وزير العدل
الاحتجاز الشرطه لنحو 40 حافله كانت
تستخدم لنقل المتظاهرين مضيفا ان
التحقيقات ستركز على من قام بتنظيم
الاحتجاجات وتمويلها
[موسيقى]